[Music]
Robert Spencer year for jihad watch a
program of the David Horowitz Freedom
Center and for the Center for Security
Policy the establishment media remains
committed to the narrative that Muslims
are far more often victims of
Islamophobia than perpetrators of
terrorist activity and so many jihadis
in the u.s. get very little press
attention just in the last few weeks
five Muslims were involved in courtroom
proceedings connected with Jihad terror
activity indicating that the jihad
against Americans and against the United
States as an entity is ongoing but you
were not likely to have heard about
these men on the evening news
Hika Kane Fox News reported recently
that a Hawaii based Army soldier was
obsessed with videos depicting terrorism
beheadings suicide bombings and other
violence and he watched them in his
bedroom for hours every day a
confidential informant told agents who
put a tracking device on the soldier's
car during an investigation that led to
an indictment charging him with
attempting to support the Islamic state
Isis group Ikaika Kang according to the
informant would watch these videos for
four to five hours every day once the
informant joined him and remembered
feeling sick to his stomach while Kang
laughed and insulted the victims Kang
said that if he were to do something
like shoot up a large gathering it would
be out of his hatred for white people
the wicked and non-muslims Edward Archer
in Philadelphia the trial recently began
of Archer a convert to Islam who in
January 2016 shot a Philadelphia police
officer 13 times at close range and
still failed to kill him thank God when
Judge Liang Tucker asked Archer to enter
a plea
Archer replied I don't plead to anyone
but Allah Edward Archer said he shot
Philadelphia police officer Jesse
Hartnett because police bend laws that
are contrary to the teachings of the
Quran but Philadelphia Mayor Jim Kenney
who's one of the bigger fools on this
planet immediately announced that the
shooting had nothing to do with being a
Muslim or following the Islamic faith
this denial and willful ignorance in is
no way to win a war and a very good way
to lose it Joshua Cummings recently in
Denver convert to Islam named Joshua
Cummings got a life sentence for the
murder of Scott Vaughn Lincoln a Denver
transit security guard Cummings like
King had served in the army
more recently however he had pledged
allegiance to the Islamic state and in
January 2017 he came up behind van
Lincoln and shot him in the neck
investigators say they have found no
link between this brutal murder and
Cummings allegiance to Isis but all that
means is that they haven't found an Isis
membership card in Cummings wallet or
phone records stating that he talked to
anyone in Iraq or Syria in reality
Cummings was heeding the call that the
Islamic state issued in September 2014
it went like this
so omoi he'd do not let this battle pass
you by wherever you may be you must
strike that soldiers patrons and troops
of the tawa heat strike they're police
security and intelligence members as
well as their treacherous agents also
recently a Muslim named Mahad Abdul Aziz
Abdera Homme pleaded guilty to stabbing
to police last November at the Mall of
America in Minnesota in a statement he
explained why abdul rahim said that he
was answering the call for jihad by the
chief of believer abu bakr al baghdadi
may Allah protect him and by the
mujahideen of the Islamic state I
understand he went on that the two men I
stabbed know and have explained the
reason for my attack and I am here
reaffirming that it was indeed an act of
jihad in the way of Allah he added that
Americans would never be safe as long as
your country is at war with Islam this
stabbing incident was initially reported
as an interrupted theft with no
indication that it was jihad it took the
perpetrator himself to explain to us
what it was really all about the
establishment media and law enforcement
were not up to that job issei Owais
Mohammed according to NBC Chicago he say
a waist Mohammad was sentenced for lying
on his passport application he said that
he plans to visit Canada but instead he
went to Egypt in Egypt he was arrested
they need
and authorities sent him back to the
United States what was he doing in Egypt
why was he detained there and why did he
lie we don't know and there's more the
FBI began investigating Mohamed in April
2017 after his family in Kansas City
reported him missing and said they were
worried that he'd gone overseas to take
part in jihad despite all this
prosecutors say they found no direct
evidence of terrorism activity by
Muhammed considering that the FBI would
not know jihad activity from shinola
that's not really reassuring while all
this was happening in Los Angeles a man
pleaded no contest to disparaging
Muslims which apparently is now a crime
in California it's good to see that LA
law enforcement officials have their
priorities straight ahran Robert Spencer
[Music]